now forgoing bread - do I really have to
say that every [ __ ] Tottenham skit
very impossible clip it's a game that
you brothers have suggested about five
[ __ ] million times that the fact that
it's called the impossible quiz has been
a reason for me not wanting to play it
but sometimes I just like to live
dangerous the glasses are unrelated
though all right let's do it
how many holes in Nepal oh there's two
well now just [ __ ] with me
how many ho holds how many horrors in a
polo polo is French which means artistic
alligator and there's about four of them
in UK okay
can a match box no but the tip of course
this is yeah answer this question
backwards tennis elbow okay click the
answer good now is this [ __ ] easy put
the mouse on here now don't touch the
blue oh I broke my screen you don't
actually think I broke it did you the
square of onion what the [ __ ] is a
shallot Oh shallots like anything you
google you'll get girls a shallow
shallots yeah it's gotta be shallot yeah
the answer is really big I have a
feeling as this one infinity an elephant
really an elephant search
I got a search for the answer yeah
alright I feel like I'm not I'm doing
pretty [ __ ] good actually what was
the answer to Question 2 how the [ __ ] do
I remember wait Kristin to a thing go
back can a match box
no but the ting oh of course I don't
remember I will have one life come on
this is the 1 million dollar question
how many holes in a polo for this one
what this why choose food
I've tried eating a yellow glove before
and it tastes it like a yellow club I
have made out with some grandmas but I
wouldn't eat them I have not eaten an
eye I guess it I know why would it be an
eye pads why shut up
which one was it that one okay she was
food I don't [ __ ] know Sharon and is
there logic behind any of these it's not
the eye is not the pen it's not the
chair it can't [ __ ] be the teacher
what why what oh because you eat with
them know what follows December 2nd
December 3rd 142 Dwarfs
I clicked but I thought would be the
dumbest answer click the smallest that
one right that that one yet what sound
does a Bell make it's not whoop it's not
fron that's that one what can you put in
a bucket to make it lighter and torched
yes [ __ ] smart this is why I go to
study engineering and shake night
waiting us this is gonna take me [ __ ]
forever what
hahahahahaha why did it matter to
thinking about that because I'm an idiot
that's why what is the seventh letter of
the alphabet ABCDE
I don't need to count on my fingers is
there some [ __ ] alphabet to [ __ ] I
don't know but why is it eight so the
answer is 17 funds it or not why the
[ __ ] do I know that's to be waters what
it's not walrus are you serious oh there
it will are ah [ __ ] I'm dumb stop hammer
time color in the correct order
I don't know who boogie is is boogie a
guy okay so blue orange green green oh
[ __ ] okay Deal or No Deal how can there
be a correct [ __ ] answer to a [ __ ]
dick deal rhymes with seal and seal
doesn't have a deal and the people who
don't have a deal are usually not a seal
okay let's think this again Deal or No
Deal
see ya watch carefully what the [ __ ]
does n what come ah that one
okay not that scared I don't know why
why why someone [ __ ] tell me save
changes to entitled
Kancil Brian Oh God what what the [ __ ]
some would call this [ __ ] I call
this I don't give a [ __ ]
click the ving lights how do you kill a
werewolf
finally a question I know god of course
it's bad shoe polish because they
contain silver or something
which of these plays names doesn't exist
it's there seriously a place called [ __ ]
there is a place called sweat sweat farm
Brown Willie how about that
there it is right in probably USA
somewhere in UK nice I can't wait to go
to brown Willie that seems lovely a
[ __ ] field no way there's a [ __ ] field
there's a [ __ ] field of course ours
no no ours facie there's no R spazzy
yeah I guess I could've guessed that I
hope you've been paying attention to the
question numbers what what is what is
that is art that's what it about let bun
a fairy cake and abundance
it's an abundance of course what flavor
is cardboard I don't think it's Agnes
okay what about honey
really really I'm not gonna do I'm not
gonna do that I'm not gonna do that I'll
put my mouse wherever the [ __ ] I wanna
find oh god now don't touch the grip but
I am touching the green but this is easy
would that this is a trap I swear to god
this is a trap that was a trap wasn't it
yeah shut up
whoa Wolf Wolf Wolf well that was
[ __ ] easy what are the main
ingredients of shampoo diarrhea where is
it
no well that's they obviously don't know
I gotta skip this bitched how many
letters in his hand five six seven eight
nine of course of course of [ __ ]
course oh good there's a [ __ ] speech
babe what are the main ingredients baby
Cham and human faeces nice cats and
whelks rock and sausages baby chant yes
it's not [ __ ] 9 that's her [ __ ]
shut up ok it's not 9 it's not 10
it's [ __ ] 8 really elephants don't
like mice what what happened what what
oh my god man I'm stupid turn it to
click this one to carry on I don't trust
this
[Music]
holy shutdown by [ __ ] genius I don't
know a wingless fly a walk right of
course
God can you get this question wrong I'm
a genius Mary Rose sat on a pin oh
really
Mary Rose ha ha ha burst her pot oh
first her pals I don't know why
cylindrical adventures
don't touch pink hmm if only you had a
bridge how the [ __ ] do I get a bridge
duck get out of here
magnificent tail breasts what is the
question
it's gotta be a what is the answer to
life the universe everything hint it's
42 oh thanks appreciate it
okay wait there's 44 43 42
I am the smartest mother Bridget makes
everyone tom Chris told you I told you
oh god how the [ __ ] am I gonna solve
this is this a puzzle
click there hey you gotta skip this one
best flash ever oh my god you killed
sunny crew you bastard
what what is this [ __ ] I have one life
come on I can't click anyway oh now I
can I don't dare to click though yes -
boy come on snake snake yes which is the
correct spelling it's PAP slap this wow
last question remember blue red blue
yellow 100 and watch it - shut up
what oh ok fight die I did it carrot is
back
what has been seen good I have to end
this episode here I don't know how much
left there is but I think we did pretty
[ __ ] good if you enjoyed leave a like
I really appreciate it thanks for
watching hit subscribe to human birth
today I'll see you Bruce in the next one
let me know if you want part two stay
awesome really love you
[Music]